live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving in storage Studio it's the Ramsay
show where America hangs out to have a
conversation about your life and your
money I am your host Jade warshaw joined
to me I write
JD money can I call you that you can
call me whatever you want come on John
deloney we're taking calls about your
life and money give us a call hit us up
the number is triple eight eight two
five five two two five and look whatever
it is you want to talk about whether
it's something going on with your budget
you're trying to take a vacation you
don't know if you can afford it you're
trying to buy a car get out of a car
whatever it is and of course John mental
health expert he's got you covered on
anything on that side of things whatever
you call about we'll have an opinion on
I'm I'm certain of it and it will be
worth about what you're paying for so
bring it up we're wrong or right all
right let's go to Michael he's in
Nashville Tennessee what's going on
Michael
hey Jade and John how are y'all doing
doing good how are you I'm doing good
um the basis of my question is uh we are
my wife and I will be preparing to live
off of one income when she starts
nursing school next year in May
um so I have some ideas on on what we
should do in the meantime to prepare for
that but I just wanted to and I could
provide more context if you want me to
well yeah can you tell me a little bit
more about what you're going down to one
income tell me what you're worried about
well I'm not really worried I just want
to try to uh knock out two financial
goals while while we're doing this um
basically should we take her paychecks
that she's making now until she starts
nursing school in 11 months and pretend
like we're living off of my income only
uh budget as if that's the case and take
her income now and put that towards the
mortgage or savings or or kind of what
should we do with that well I do think
it's important to discover if you can
live off the one income I think that's
really important but until you get to
that point you know I would say let's go
through the baby steps and get as far
along as possible and then kind of
recalculate because as it stands now
without paying off any more debt without
saving any more money what have you are
you able to live off the one income
yes okay so that's we have relief there
we can take it out big deep breath how
comfortably
pretty pretty I mean it it's obviously
going to be tighter than it is that
we're on baby steps four and six so
we're completely out of debt five
doesn't apply because we don't have
children so we have our emergency fund
we're saving we're investing and paying
down the mortgage right now
um if we go down to my income only I
mean it would definitely be tighter but
I've already done the budget and we can
definitely we can definitely make it
work
now when you go into when she goes into
the nursing school you're able to pay
cash as well
there's a couple of options there's
Tennessee reconnect which would actually
pay for her school in full but if that
fails we we do have the money set aside
for her to pay for the nursing school in
addition to our emergency fund winning
very good so you mentioned earlier that
there were I feel like you said there
were two things that you wanted to
tackle before this
did I get that right no it's just just
paying down the mortgage in preparation
of this since we have the two incomes
currently should we further paying down
the mortgage by just taking by just
pretending like because right now we're
budgeting off of both of our incomes
together
um so should we take her income that
she's making now for the next 11 months
until she starts nursing school and
maybe put like half of it in savings and
half of it towards the mortgage to
further to further those goals I mean I
wouldn't necessarily look at it by
income at this point I would look at it
as in our budget what's our margin and
what extra money do we have to do XYZ as
opposed to just saying oh we're only
going to take your income because who
knows you you said that even on your
income there's margin so I don't want
you to just do it by paycheck if that
makes sense I want you to do it by this
is how like because remember we're
budgeting by month and it's not like you
guys have a fire that you have to put
out somewhere so it's not like you're in
this crazy mode you've got this amount
of money and this is your budget for the
month of what month are we in John for
the level of God mayor June or Goliath
okay so we're going in it's May 30th
we're going into June so you look at and
you say okay this is our income for June
what's our budget and then you do the
same thing for July you already know
that the time is coming where it's going
to go down to one income and when that
time comes then you'll say okay how much
margin do we have to you know make sure
we're hitting baby step four and then of
course whatever is extra we're doing to
baby step six and so you just take it as
it comes as opposed to
I don't know I feel like you're trying
to preempt it in some way but I don't
think that's necessary here yeah dude
it's almost 100 of the time the cuter
you try to get with it or the more
sophisticated you try to get with it the
more you're going to screw it up play it
straight until I mean you've already
you've already set yourself up to in
such a good position because you've got
all the money for nursing school if the
scholarship doesn't work out you don't
owe anybody any money except your
mortgage and you've already got you got
margin in your budget so you've You've
Won and now you're sitting around you're
gonna over complicate it you're gonna
spin it up a little bit I would just
play it straight and go on about your
day man there's not really a right or
wrong way to do this unless you over
complicate it and then end up falling
down I love that thanks for the call
Michael good stuff good stuff I love it
when people call in and they think like
there's a big like problem but then we
find out there is no problem I know but
that was one of them no problem there
um let's see if we can take another call
real quick do we have time yeah let's
try it let's try Sam in Portland Oregon
what's going on Sam
partying
good uh hey real quick so uh that's my
question uh my fiance and I we got
engaged two and a half weeks ago
congrats um thank you we're we're both
on two different baby steps at the
moment
um and we're starting a plan for a
wedding we're in the very beginning
phases of it
and we're looking to figure out the best
way to handle this
um paying for it
what's that you're talking about
handling paying for the wedding or
handling your debt well no because we're
we're going to pay for it in cash like
that's not the question like you know
there's there's that's how we're going
to do it um but just as far as like how
we should because she's in baby step two
and I recently just got on to baby step
three right
so when you get married you're gonna be
back in baby step two because her debt
becomes y'all's death yes now so yep
have you set a budget for this wedding
because
that's really how we figure out what we
need to do next
well yeah so
um yeah we're waiting like a year and a
half or so to get married
why are you waiting so long because he
wants her to pay off that debt so he
doesn't have to do it
thank you why would you wait a year and
a half be honest be honest Sam you're
right
listen because get five friends and go
to the justice of the peace next week
you can throw a party in a year and a
half what are you doing John my guy does
not want to pay off his he's like I paid
off my debt listen to you you are hey
she's get you may not have any credit
card debt but you got all kind of
baggage you're carrying around that
she's gonna have to sort through over
the course of your marriage just get
married and y'all work through this
thing together man I'm not mad at that
what do you think about that no I no
that I mean that's that's an excellent
plan I guess the really the only reason
that I'm being honest with you here the
only reason why we wait is just because
you know we do want to have you know a
traditional wedding and I guess you know
you can do that you know after the whole
you know going to the courthouse and
getting married thing
um but you know just as you know was
important for us both to do that hey the
only reason I'm messing with you I know
I know the only reason I'd wait on this
is if you're waiting to save up to
actually be able to pay cash for what
the wedding don't wait because you're
trying to pay off debt don't wait
because you're trying to get more
savings don't wait because you don't
want to pay off her debt secretly get
married save up for the wedding pay cash
for the wedding that's the way I'm doing
it John yeah and she's a baby step too
she can she can stop paying off her desk
stockpile cash just make sure you get to
this wedding without owing anybody
anything that's the way to do it this is
the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place here's
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and next week's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to netsuite.com Ramsey today okay
and set up a free product tour that's
netsuite.com Ramsey
[Music]
all right you're listening to the Ramsay
show I'm your host today Jade warshaw
joined by Dr John deloney we're taking
calls all day long all afternoon long
about your life and your money be sure
to give us a call Triple eight eight two
five five two two five and more
importantly John we need to talk about
this guys uh the fact that we're here
the fact that we're on the air we get to
do this crazy job every afternoon is
because you guys are out there listening
and we're so grateful that you guys
select the Ramsay show on your podcast
on YouTube and we really just want to
ask you guys to keep doing that keep
listening to the show keep liking the
show hey share the show if there's an
episode that you love text it to a buddy
or share it on social media that's how
we keep going that's how it continues to
pop up up in the algorithms so that you
guys can continue to watch it and that's
good for us and it's good for you so
like it share it subscribe to it uh even
leave a review if it's if it's a nice
reason if it's kind and also if you're
one of those people that just sits at
home and watches the news all the time
and you start to get so mad at your
neighbors
those idiots if they would just if they
would just they gotta learn
if you want people to get
life-changing advice on how to handle
their money how to handle their
marriages and their relationships
just simply subscribing to the show
kicks it up into your neighbor's
algorithms when they're out there it
makes the show go up and up and up and
it puts it in front of more people and
it's an easy way for you to help your
neighbor you don't even have to talk to
them even though I wish you would do
that too so yeah it really helps out I'm
gonna I have several people on my list
that I can just be like you know what
you need Dr John deloney in your life
here's here's the podcast there you go
all right today's question of the day
it's brought to you by neighborly your
hub for Home Services all right now that
the weather is warming up it's time to
enjoy your outdoor space neighborly's
mosquito Joe service can help you make
your outdoor area pest free so you can
enjoy being outside in Comfort that's
what I'm talking about visit
neighborly.com to reach your local
mosquito Joe today all right today's
question comes from Bella in
Pennsylvania Bella writes I'm 23 years
old and I'm trying to figure out if I'm
doing the right thing when trying to pay
off my debt I have 50 000 in student
loans I make 65 000 a year and I have a
side hustle that brings in 500 to 700
extra each month my parents have said if
I live with them they will not ask for
rent as long as I'm working on paying
off my debt okay I can save a minimum of
2 600 bucks a month to put towards
paying off my loans with the extra
income I can be debt free by next
December if not sooner
I'm struggling with this plan because my
friends keep telling me to move out of
my parents house and rent somewhere and
my parents are telling me just to make
minimum payments or a little extra on my
loans and live a little both my friends
and family are telling me not to get rid
of my credit cards because I know I have
a because I have a credit score I'll
never be able to buy a house with no
credit which I know is not true but I
don't know how long it will take my
credit score to go away am I making the
right choice by choosing to stay at home
one more year and work until I'm debt
free then find a place to rent until I'm
ready to buy a home or do I need to make
myself more financially independent
while trying to pay this off how do I
explain to my friends and family I
cannot and will not live like this
anymore and I'm ready to be free there's
like 15 questions in this one question
here the problem is she's way smarter
than her friends
it's pretty straightforward and she's
struggling with the fact that she's
smarter than her friends yeah
and I I wonder okay let's pull this
thing apart from top to bottom all right
let's go so yo 50 000 bucks mom and dad
say you can live with us and we're not
gonna ask for rent as long as you're
working on paying off debt that's red
flag for me number one I got no problem
with people moving in with their parents
moving into uh she my wife and I sold
our house and moved into a residence
hall for crying out loud here's the
thing you have to have an end date in
mind you've got to have a some structure
or some boundaries around this or it
turns into this weird you wake up and
you're 29 years old and you've been
living at home for a long time because
once Mom and Dad get used to you living
there it's gonna be well you know why
don't you just why don't you just save
up some more money and you put down
payment on a house Etc so if you live
with them great if you all come up with
this Arrangement y'all shake hands like
grown-ups now but it's a business
Arrangement that's gonna last this long
put it six months nine months uh one
year put a put a date on it so that
everybody's on the same page so you
gotta go or you gotta go the second
thing is stop listening to your friends
your friends are broke and they're dumb
stop stop listening to them
okay let me back out Jade you and your
husband paid off almost half a million
dollars in loans yes yes and y'all were
freakishly talented and I know that you
ran around with artists and performers
and business managers who were all
telling you how you should be living
your life yes there is it's fake it's
such a it's all phony like look like you
have this it looks like that yeah
exactly so how did how did you manage
because I'm not a good person to ask
because I just don't care right I simply
just don't care I'll just say like I
like my old truck and it's just I like
it how did you handle dealing with that
much pressure as a new college grad a
newlywed trying to make this thing
happen what you just said is the answer
not caring the the moment John that you
stop caring what other people think is
the moment that you can reach your full
potential like that's the moment the
moment you're like I could care less if
somebody uh sees what the inside of my
house looks like and they're not
impressed by it I could care less if
somebody sees what I'm car driving in
the car in the parking lot and it's not
you know brand new or it's not like
what's cool the moment you could care
less that yeah I wore I'm wearing the
same outfit I wore last week at this
time is the moment that you can achieve
what you need to achieve financially
because we do so much out of hey what's
what's he gonna think about that what
are they going to think of everybody
else at the restaurants ordering you
know appetizer uh dinner dessert and I
just order an inexpensive appetizer
because that's my budget like the minute
you just go I don't care watch just
watch what happens and this girl right
here
she has the right instincts like she's
the one like what you said hey you can
live at home but put a date on it she's
the one that said hey I can do this by
next December her parents didn't do that
she did that her her friends are the
ones saying hey you know maybe don't do
this maybe and it's bothering her
because she's got better instincts and I
would just challenge her what's her name
Bella Bella in Pennsylvania man just go
with your instincts what you're thinking
is right don't just make payments pay it
off your parents they obviously don't
understand that because they said as
long as you're making minimum payments
no you have it in your brain to pay it
off so pay it off and yeah Devil May
care who cares what what your parents
say my guess is if your parents said
just make payments they probably have
payments and I want to flip this around
for those of you who are running with
people that you give what I think is one
of the most
um holy names you can give somebody
which is the title of friend oh
I had a couple of buddies when I
graduated college I moved in with him it
was Todd and John and when I told them
I'm trying to pay this thing off both of
them had their college covered when I
said hey I'm not going out I'm not doing
this I want to pay this they got
together on their own without me
and they came back when I wrote my third
of the rent check and they said hey
we're not taking your money you got to
mow the yard you got a goal and we're
going to back you up on it and so that
to me is friends who walk alongside you
when you say I want to change my life
and they're like we'll figure out a way
to be a part of this thing we're not
just going to sit on the side like job's
friends and and throw pennies at you oh
come on and that's the thing like she
has the ability to influence them
whether she realizes it or not right now
they might be naysaying they might be
kind of chuckling at her but if she
walks down this track and she pays off
her debt and then she sees her credit
score go to zero and then she realizes
she can still do all the things with a
zero credit score and her friends start
to see that they will change uh this
weekend I went to dinner with a bunch of
friends and at the end of the night my
buddy was like hey come see the car I
just bought in cash and so we all go out
to the you know parking lot we're
looking at it and then my other buddy is
like yeah and we just got a second car
and we paid cash and she pulls her car
up and on the way home Sam and I were
just like wow all of these folks this
was a domino effect because it started
with us buying a car in cash and then
everybody going why would you do that
why would you do that and now we're
seeing it have this effect in our friend
Circle my buddy was like well you know
I'm on a budget now I got to pull out my
debit card I'm like yes like this is it
and so what she's doing I promise you if
they're smart they're gonna start to
take note and they're going to learn
from what she's doing right now so big
deal and it's a tiny tiny little light
in the dark that makes all the
difference that people can find their
way it can be Pitch Black in a teeny
tiny Candlelight on the other end of a
field people can find it if you will
just
just hold hold tight as my as my buddy
great author SK Dahlstrom says be the
only one just be the only one
when you know you're right you know
you're doing right you know you're
changing your entire family tree yep be
the only one don't be afraid to be the
only one that's right so go ahead Bella
make those payments pay it pay the
payments to pay it off don't lollygag on
it stay set it set in time when you're
gonna get out of the house and then from
there on just keep going decide that
you're going to live a debt-free
lifestyle no payments in sight I'm proud
of you this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
folks you know that sinking feeling when
you make an offer on a house you love
and then you hear there's another offer
you need the Churchill Mortgage home
buyer Edge super fast pre-approval and a
secured interest rate plus a five
thousand dollar seller guarantee gives
your offer the best chance of being
accepted the home buyer Edge from
Churchill gives you an advantage over
those other guys go to
churchillmortgage.com today to learn
more
[Music]
thank you
what's up guys this is Jay and you're
listening to the Ramsay show I'm joined
by my co-host this hour Dr John deloney
and I got to tell you guys a little
something uh but before I do be sure to
give us a call the numbers Triple A
eight two five five two two five if you
want to chat about whatever's going on
in your life as it pertains to your
money we got Dr John here so
I know I know people are setting up for
the summer and they have just exhaled
after they're either this is the last
week of school or last week was the last
week of school
I know you're in the middle of it and
people are dealing with family drama
they're dealing with financial drama I
can't figure out how the Summer's gonna
work
be brave and make the call I know you're
sitting there on the phone and you're
like I would love to know what they
think about my husband just did like
call us triple eight eight two five five
two two five don't just sit there you've
got a lot of stuff we're gonna walk
alongside you and we'll figure it out
together I love that and look we can
change your name we don't you don't have
to say that today we'll change where
you're from Tennessee yeah just yeah
make up something you can even call in
with an accent my name is Dan actually
so this isn't even my name no not really
we'll change anything we'll change it
all that's right just give us a call
because it's so important that we we
help you through that all right now I'm
going to take a very sharp left turn
John and I'm going to talk about our ten
dollar sale which ends tomorrow
um guys we're doing a ten dollar sale
and it's your last chance that you're
gonna have to get your hands on our
life-changing books and tools okay so
listen carefully if you're looking to
get out from under a pile of credit card
bills
um maybe you're just like I'm so sick of
my money and my paycheck getting eaten
up every single month then the book for
you is The Total Money Makeover by Dave
Ramsey and I can tell you from
experience it changed my life that's the
one that you need I can tell you
millions of people have used the plan in
this book to get control of their life
their money for good they've changed
their complete 180 of their family tree
and let me tell you the book's only ten
dollars so get your hands on that ten
dollar challah you can also get Dave's
latest book baby steps millionaires
again one that I have read cover to
cover it's just ten dollars in this book
Dave's going to show you how to build a
legacy guys with solid investing plans
and once you and you're going to do that
once you've paid off all your debt plus
you're going to be inspired by real life
stories of actual factual millionaires
who got there by following all seven
baby steps so I'm telling you Total
Money Makeover check baby steps
millionaires a check and not only that
but if you want to improve on your
relationships your mental health pick up
John deloney's questions for humans I
got stacks of those at the house I'm
telling you I'm using this stuff or own
your past change your future which I've
also read John deloney and I remember
can I just tell you guys my first
interaction with John deloney on the
interwebs was I quoted something I was
reading your book and I highlighted it I
tagged you in it and I said where's the
lie and you thought that I was coming
for you and you were like what are you
talking about there's no lie here you
know it's like no oh John this is what
the kids are saying I know I my wife
tells me I was born in the wrong Century
I don't get the jokes that I'll get them
but anyway all of these books are on
sale for just ten dollars each remember
the ten dollar sale ends tomorrow so
shop these deals before they're gone go
to ramseysolutions.com
sale wow that was something all right
let's go ahead and take a call we got
Ashton and Tuscaloosa Alabama what's
going on Ashton
uh not much guys
um thanks for taking my call you're not
an Alabama football fan are you
of course I am I live in Tuscaloosa man
I know I was trying to be I was trying
to be funny and you made it weird all
right go ahead okay we're sorry um okay
so this is my my question I work
full-time I'm a truck driver a local
truck driver
um I I would love to go back to school
and get a degree I'm kind of leaning
towards Physical Therapy
um you know yeah it'd be fulfilling good
pay
um I heard that the the work life
balance is great
um but here's my dilemma
the job I'm currently at is night shift
12 hour shifts 60 hours a week and I
spoke with my boss trying to do a
part-time
and in a really nice Corporate Way they
said no
um
so I'm kind of struggling because I've
been looking for other jobs something I
could do and you know cash flow to
school while I'm going
um but nothing is like even close let me
back out a little bit let me back out
for a second why Physical Therapy did
you get on a website that just said this
is a good job and it's got good
work-life balance and you're like I
think I'll do this or do you actually
want to sit walking alongside people who
have new knees and new hips or who are
struggling with things and you want to
and you want to like where's this
interest coming from
um
what my mother who you know adorably
raised me my dad passed away when I was
younger she's always worked in the
medical field
um and like truck driving is you know
great in a lot of ways but there's no
like I'm not I'm not helping people and
I feel like with this I could help
people you know who are struggling or
whatever and um you know see it all the
way through from the beginning of the
process to the end where they're better
you know bring something listen before
you work nights which is going to mean
you're going to be tired but this is
excellent before you haul off and quit
your job or start a like a a medical
program at a university I want you to go
spend a couple of days shadowing a
physical therapist like see what they do
day in and day out and make sure this is
the shift you want to make I'm not
saying it's not but after I was quote
unquote all done with all my school and
then I decided I want to go get into
some more credentials and counseling I
went and sat with counselors and this is
what they do all day every day and made
sure before I went and spent a bunch of
time and a bunch of money and lost a lot
of time away from my family to go jump
into that because I knew it was
something I wanted to do now I'm gonna
call you on this okay
your company says you can't go full time
fine
but I got a master's degree and two phds
working full-time with a family
you can do it if you want to you work
night shift and you're gonna be
exhausted when you get up in the morning
but you can go to class in the morning
and you do a part-time School shift
while you get your credentials
underneath you or you can take some
online courses to level out which you're
gonna have to do anyway and you can do
that while you're on the road staying in
a hotel or staying at home when you're a
local drivers you're on hotels but you
can figure the school part out easier
than you can figure out the work part is
that right
yes that's that's where I would start if
I were you man I'd hang on to that
full-time job
okay I agree I mean you want to keep
making a living while you're
transitioning into what you want to do
and I think sometimes we want that to be
just a full just a quick transition like
trade apples for oranges and now we're
you know eating oranges now but it
doesn't always happen like that you have
to kind of make that a smooth transition
and go and sometimes you go through a
season where it's just not very
comfortable let's be honest about that
you're exhausted you miss out on cool
weekend things you're gonna miss out on
Hunt trips and fishing trips and you're
gonna miss out on dinners with some date
you have that's just part of the
sacrifice you're making to make a
complete life 180 change that's all good
okay well you know can you kind of say
something guys I'm gonna be honest I
don't
have time now to do a lot of that stuff
like anyway
he's like I have no life right now guys
yeah I don't I mean you're working 60
hours a week right
yeah and it's night shift it's I don't I
don't know if you guys ever had a night
shift shop it is so hard to sleep during
the day
can you at least get to 40 hours because
I mean at least 40 hours you're still
full time
and listen that's that's what I wanted
that's what I meant by part-time was
like full time yeah yeah that's what I
meant but they they still they still
told me no so like what are you making
in this job
uh about 75 000 a year before taxes okay
is there let me just ask this is there a
way to transition to another job doing
driving like what you're doing where the
hours are less so that you can start
this education I'm
um I've I've talked to a few places and
one place would not tell me how much
they paid over the phone so I was like
okay you know but um I'm still probably
going to schedule like an interview to
go and see you should be good look at
this point I think that's you've just
got to do a lot of research and figure
out what's out there figure out what
this is going to look like for you
because you're right at 60 hours a week
John honestly how
but also if you don't got any kids
you're not married you can making 75 000
is great but you are talking about a
radical life shift and that radical life
shift means you have to give up a lot of
the comfortable things and so it may be
we're gonna take a pay cut from 75 000
to 30 000 and that's enough to pay my
bills and to pay my tuition and get me
through on beans and rice to the end of
this degree just gonna be how bad you
want it man no part of this will be
comfortable and you're gonna have to get
over the comfortable part and go do
something really hard oh that's so true
John is shooting you straight Ashton
thanks for the call this is the Ramsay
show
thank you
[Music]
what's going on guys you're listening to
the Ramsay show I'm your host Jade
warshaw to my right Dr John deloney and
we're taking your calls all afternoon
about your life and your money the
number is simple triple eight eight two
five five two two five and here's the
thing uh if you're a new listener and
you want to dive deeper into the Ramsay
baby steps here's the thing we talk all
the all day about baby steps and gazelle
intensity and beans and rice and baby
step four and all these things that
you're probably like man I just started
listening I have no idea what you're
talking about uh head over to
ramseysolutions.com and just click that
get started button and it's just going
to give you everything you need to know
what the heck we're talking about we'll
help you figure out your best next step
for your financial Journey based on
exactly where you're at today and
suddenly it will all get crystal clear
and start to make sense so go to
ramseysolutions.com and click the get
started button that's all you got to do
all right let's take a call we got Cole
from Memphis Tennessee see in town
what's going on
hey guys uh I went from
um being in babyset four to being uh
sixty thousand dollars in debt whoa what
happened I need some advice what
happened man
uh well in uh September 21 uh my dad
died and we had added a baby to the
family wow at the same time
um and I just kind of quit doing
everything that I should have been doing
and
um recently uh went to therapy and found
that uh I've kind of been blaming myself
for my dad's death uh and have moved
past that and looked at everything that
I should have been doing in the past
year and a half and I'm like okay now I
I'm not making enough income to even
make my monthly minimums on the credit
card so I don't know what to do what
happened with your dad man
um he uh
he went in the hospital I took him to
the hospital and
um he had a event over the night and
like the next day he was like a dementia
patient and uh it was about two months
of that until he passed away it was uh I
mean he basically died from Wet Brain
from throat from alcohol systems uh
related stuff
does he struggle with alcohol his your
whole life
yes so my guess is you've been being a
parent for a long long time since you're
a little boy huh
yes
you've been covering for him and picking
up after him for a long long time huh
correct so I want you to hear me say
this directly I know your counselor
probably told you the same thing
your old man was real real lucky to have
you as his son
he won the the lottery getting you as
his son
and two
his demons were his demons and they
weren't because of you
right
that's right in fact you were the light
in his life so any any time that thought
Pops in your head it's a lie and you
know it's a lie and it's not right and
it doesn't make it any easier but but
you can walk forward knowing hey that's
not true I do want to challenge you on
your language about
now that my dad's like I'm I'm over that
now I don't know that you're ever gonna
be over it and that's okay it's not
really how grief works
right it'll be a lighter load and it'll
be a lighter load and a lighter load but
I don't want you to be surprised when
you wake up some days and you don't then
it's you feel sad man you lost your old
man that's a bum deal right and then you
made some dumb decisions on the back of
it because just you lost some
intentionality that happens to all of us
and you've gotten up and dusted yourself
off and now you're looking in the in the
light of day going whoa this is this is
a mess now right
yes
okay I have a hundred percent confidence
that you can walk your way through this
do you believe that
yes
if you don't trust yourself it's a waste
this is a waste of both of our time you
trust you now
I do awesome you're good man you're good
so tell us your financial situation
um yeah so I've got I've got about 36
000 in credit card debt and about thirty
thousand dollars in a personal loan and
the monthly minimums uh are almost three
grand
um and the past two years I've primarily
been doing real estate and I made 68
000 last year seventy two thousand the
year before uh but I also own an
electrical company that's just me and my
service truck
and uh I've recently like in the past
two weeks started hopping back in the
service truck and just like working like
a madman if I'm awake I'm either
installing electrical work or showing
houses
and what are you earning from that
electrical truck
um that remains to be seen because uh I
I ideally I can uh how much have you
made how much have you made a week
um well last week I made seven thousand
dollars okay that's excellent yeah don't
dismiss that don't dismiss that well
we'll see no seven you got back in your
truck 107 Grand man
so the question is what are we doing
with this money that's the question
because
um you know you've got the two sets of
payments there you said you're paying
about 3K in minimum payments every month
are you on a budget are we seeing what's
going on with the rest of your
money
yes me and my wife just spent a week of
running through every dollar and we got
all of our April and May transactions in
there and cut everything we could and uh
living expenses are about six thousand
um a month and then the 3 000 a month in
debt famous all right so here's the
thing you've done it before because
before all of this happened you're in
baby step four right so the steps
haven't changed it's the same deal man
we're taking any and all extra income
and we're putting it towards that small
estate on the debt snowball keep a
thousand dollars saved out for your
emergency fund but any extra cash that
you have lying around put it on that
smallest debt while you're making
minimum payments on everything else do
you have any savings or any other money
laying around
no okay does your wife work
uh no why not
uh because she sees a full-time mom of a
four-year-old and one-year-old all right
so she's staying at home all right
you're working this electrical truck
you're working real estate you just said
when you put your mind to it you get out
there and you earn an extra 7K that
extra right
yeah
well that's that was the only income
because uh I haven't had very many I've
only had three real estate closings this
year all right that's look if you make
seven thousand a month and that's all
you made a month I'm not mad at that
just go out and do it again plus some
the next month what's this week look
like right
um this week's looking about like three
thousand okay so ten thousand dollars
over two weeks that's a good dude you're
doing great
yeah
and then what's next week you have any
jobs lined up for next week
uh nothing lined up for next week yet
okay you may be better off spending your
time because the real estate has just
parked and if you're not in that full
time just just mad dogging it you're
gonna get run off the road by those who
are you may want to take some of that
time you're running around showing
people houses they're like I don't know
I don't know and you may want to start
making calls because you know you can
earn that money on that truck
hey just wondering well when did you get
into real estate
in 2020. okay yeah we'll play dude but
look we're seeing that we're looking
seeing a lot of folks who got in in 2020
and they weren't used to a normal seat
they made a bajillion dollars yeah but
now that it's like this it's like Oh
Real Estate no more whereas other folks
I know who have been doing real estate
for 20 years they're like hey yeah I'm
just doing my normal job this is how
it's always been it was like farming and
it rained a lot in 2020. it was great in
2021 and now it's not raining it's dry
right now so now yeah you've got to
reevaluate I Cole hear me when I say
this you've got to reevaluate was I
great at real estate and was that
something that I was really shining in
or was I just really able to take
advantage of a really good time yeah
were you fishing in a stock pond I've
made that mistake I thought I was a
great fisherman until I went to a real
Lake and I caught nothing right but man
hey you have proven to yourself you can
earn serious money and if you take that
salesman attitude that you've been
selling houses with and turn that
towards your truck I man I think you're
gonna pay this debt off in no time I
definitely think so you know I think
that he's just struggling with
[Music]
your future and we'll get you hooked up
I want you and your wife to read that
together and it'll give you a path out
man I love it all right guys that does
it for this hour of the show be sure to
join us next time this is the Ramsay
show foreign
hey what's up guys it's Jade if you love
the show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramseysolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
foreign
live it's the Ramsay show where America
hangs out to have a conversation about
your money your relationships your
marriage your mental health your work
everything I'm Dr John deloney joined
here by my good friend Jade warshaw and
we are taking your calls on just about
everything we got an opinion on it I
promise you triple eight eight two five
a five two two five and listen I read
the data I know your marriage is
struggling and I know you are looking at
your kids who just got out of school and
they already have a screen in hand and
they're in front of another screen and
you're thinking I don't want to do
another summer like this and you're
looking at your budget and you are not
going to be able to make that vacation
that you promised everybody give us a
call Triple eight eight two five five
two two five we will help you navigate
the wildness that is our lives these
days Jade
Mayhem it is Mayhem but we'll walk you
through it we'll do the best we can in
the meantime let's try to help Brady out
he's in Little Rock Arkansas what's
going on Brady
hey y'all thanks for having me hey
what's going on
hey so I work off of commission as a
real estate agent and I was just curious
as to how I should build a budget off of
that
so we're basically talking about an
irregular income that is like how much
do you fluctuate like on a normal
month to month well it actually
fluctuates quite a bit because I live in
a real small rural area I mean on
average the last two years I've made uh
right at 50 000 bulk years uh but you
know one month I might make 15 000 and
then next month I might not make
anything
so I totally understand that my husband
and I were in entertainment and it was
very much like that I call it feast and
famine because one month you could like
score big and have some great shows and
then the next month you're like asking
your agent like where's the work where's
the gig so I totally get that
um and at the end of the day it's really
setting up your budget in a way that
you're paying the the non-negotiables
first and so you're making sure like you
you understand no matter what I've got
to pay these bills right that's like
your four walls making sure that you've
got food Transportation right you're
you're keeping the car running you're
keeping keeping the rent going and then
anything else Falls below that line it's
like okay and then when I get extra
money I do this this and that so once
you know those numbers let's just say
you have let's let's say theoretically
hey in order to make my house just stay
on I need two thousand dollars or I need
three thousand dollars right but let's
say you have a month where you make ten
thousand dollars you know that you've
gotta look at that ten thousand and go
okay hypothetically I could stretch
three months out of that if I needed to
right so you start off at that Bare
Bones and then as more money comes in
it's kind of like you can work your way
down the list and do a little bit more
because you've got more set aside for
the next month does that make sense
yeah yeah so initially starting should I
go off of like say what I made the
previous month or go do the previous
year say so you've got a good Baseline
you've made fifty thousand dollars two
years in a row this year has it been
harder this year
uh no I'm actually on track to make just
a little bit more okay great that's
perfect I would keep that number at 50
and then divide that by 12 and that's
your that's your basis for how much it
takes you to get through a month
okay yeah that makes sense and when you
look back you might start to see that
there's a certain seasonality or certain
trends that set up like hey it just
seems like no matter what for whatever
reason August we always make more money
or for whatever reason you know in
December we're just killing it you're
gonna start to see those Trends develop
and that's also going to make it easier
over time to budget and see what you've
got I also you know is your wife working
uh no ma'am she is a stay-at-home mom
stay-at-home mom she does work she works
PRN as a registered nurse at a local
clinic but that's just one day a week so
I'll be honest and and take take from
this what you want uh but when I was in
that situation of having such an
irregular income for my husband and I it
gave us such peace to find a couple of
things that we also did that gave us a
stable like no matter what we know we're
getting this money and I don't know what
that looks like for you it might be
something else that you do on the side
where it's like no matter what I know
and I can always plan that I'm getting
this two thousand dollars or I can
always plan that I'm getting do you see
what I'm saying and I feel like that
could go a long way it doesn't have to
be a large amount of money but that goes
a long way when it's paired with
irregular income to give you just a
little bit of Peace of I know I can
count on this and as long as I you know
do XYZ I know where I know we're good
and I know we're gravy but at the end of
the day for you a lot of this is
being able to have the muscle to hold
back and not spend and be like okay I
know that we've got ten thousand dollars
sitting here but this month we're only
spending four thousand and the other six
thousand has to wait until the next
month or until you get another
um influx of cash let me I'm on 100
commission too let me tell you there's
not really a
you can do this any number of ways
here's how we've done it in our house
number one the emergency fund is not
this uh what I would call a flex fund
like Jade was talking about your
emergency fund is in a separate account
for when you've got to replace your roof
your air conditioner goes out it's not
to bail you out month to month and then
when we first were practicing this my
wife and I we kept what I would call a
rolling fund that was about three months
of our average salary because I was new
to this whole thing I had worked in
education for my whole career and I just
got a paycheck every month no matter how
much I worked or how much time I had off
and this is different now and so I it's
the months that you have that are really
big and I was blessed to to spend some
time in West Texas where I grew up
around I was around some Farmers one
year may be insane you may make two
million dollars one year and you may
lose 300 000 the next year depending on
how much it rains and so the goal here
is when you get those two million dollar
years you have to look ahead for the
next year and the next year and you're
just gonna do that on the month to month
so if you have that fifteen thousand
dollar month oh my gosh it'd be so
tempting to go out to eat and to go get
a new van and do all those things you
got to look and say okay I need at least
the next two or three months because
this is gonna pay my bills in case I've
got nothing in case I got nothing and
then once a year my wife and I might
roll some money into our retirement
account and we might roll some money
into long-term savings or into a money
market account or something like that
once we know we have caught up with our
months does that make sense
yeah yeah absolutely and I somewhat done
that what I do is I take 30 of every
commission check that I get and I put I
just stick it back into an account but I
do that uh for year in taxes okay I
don't have to worry about that but
that's a different that's a totally
different account that's a third account
what you're doing there that's super
smart but that can't be the money that
hey if we come on hard times we take
that money because
exactly so you've got it's it's it's a
combination you've got to have your
three to six months of expenses in your
case because of the nature of your work
you want six months of expenses so
that's saving set number one number two
yes put to put aside 25 30 of what
you're getting because you know that
you're gonna have to pay taxes and then
three as I said if you have a big month
come in every time you have a big month
come in and you know there's a lot of
margin let's set aside a little of that
margin until you've got a little bit of
a cushion so that you can start to live
your life like a normal life you know so
if you come in a couple of thousand
short you've got a piece that you can
pull from but it also lets you do the
things that you need to do depending on
the baby step you're on like investing
or putting aside do you know what I'm
saying because you want to feel like
you're able to do those things and
you're not just waiting the name of this
game is discipline and It's just tough
It's just yeah that's the only
difference is that she's got to be
disciplined you do it's not easy guys
living on living on irregular income it
is not for the faint of heart but you
can do it it just takes a little bit of
discipline and a little bit of really
intentionality on your part but you can
do it this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Applause]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's back there why
they're watching guarantee and
hands-free see whyblinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings go to blinds.com now
and save 45 off selected products visit
blinds.com today for more info
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
hey what's going on guys this is the
Ramsay show I'm your host Jade warshaw
joined by Dr John deloney I love that I
think it's cool when you have a doctor
in front of your name it just gives you
the clout man it sounds great until your
friends get a hold of it and it's not
that great and besides like when you get
a doctorate your name changes like you
go from John deloney to doctor alone but
in my house my mom and my wife were Dr
deloni before me and so I've got these
two gangster women ahead of me and it
like by the time I came around to it
they're like oh that's cute take out the
trash it didn't matter that's amazing I
love it well give us a call the number
is triple eight eight two five five two
two five and we will chop it up with you
in the meantime we got Abigail who did
just that Abigail what's going on
Toronto Ontario Canada
hi this is very exciting thank you for
taking my call most definitely how can
we hope
so I'm thinking about sewing my dog
grooming business to my contractor
because I'm burnt out and I really don't
make enough money managing it wow
interesting so if you were to sell it
like have you done the research what are
you know what could you sell it for do
you have a buyer what would you do next
those are my questions
um yeah so I've looked first out like a
couple Warriors or appraisal places but
they only really do like real estate and
we don't have real estate
um it would just be like my client list
and my equipment and stuff
um and then I would be looking to sell
it to my contractor she works for me
full-time she has a lot of health issues
which is why I'm feeling a little Brent
out lately
um I'm just having to do more work in
the business but still not making enough
on it so so let me it's funny you say
that the first question that came to my
head when you said you were burnt out
with your business was
are you truly done with this this part
of your life right and and I've been
there too or are you burned out by the
the ecosystem you've created around this
job
here's my question if you fired this
person
and would that bring joy back into your
business would anyone to bring cash flow
back into your business
no I don't know um she
she does she works full-time we usually
booked about six to eight weeks in
advance like full-time four to five dogs
a day kind of thing
um how are you not making enough money
though
increase your prices
um
we have we're increased like every year
okay um the problem is he makes sixty
percent plus tips
um so she makes too much in my opinion
um and I'm only taking home about 15
maybe that but she works for you to
clean the form yes don't you get to
decide you get to decide
she's been working with me for three
years and I
don't feel right about taking an income
away from her if that makes sense okay
but you're willing to lose your job
yeah this is I have I have a dog
boarding business
um like which is my full-time other
business and then I have two kids at
home
um so this is kind of
the side on the side right now okay so
let me back up what's your question I
just I just we just started answering
your questions what is your question
should she say
yeah so I guess I'm wondering like
um how to present the idea to her and uh
like what it's worth and everything what
how much are you guys pulling in monthly
and yearly
uh last year the gross income was about
82 000. okay
and how much of that did you see
uh 12 000. and how much of that did she
see like would you pay yourself and
would you pay her
uh she made about 47 000 last year
and what'd you make
12 000
. wait what hold on it's your business
and I'm sorry we're not laughing at you
we want to make sure we understand no
I'm trying to think of what Dave Ramsey
would do if I was like hey man uh I make
60 of his company she's got it best best
backwards yes thank you say it right yes
because this is your business you should
be making the bigger percentage she's
your employee set this whole thing up
you're bringing it you're doing all the
work and you've got somebody that you're
Contracting in
I I'm help me understand because I'm so
confused how she's making so much more
than you more more than double triple
yeah so I I just do the managing so I
stay at home
um I'm with my kids and then I do my
boarding business about 36 hours a week
um and then she works full-time at the
salon so that's why she makes
more than me so I do like the managing
and everything so you're just almost a
passive owner then but wait wait wait
wait wait wait I gotta call something
out because I I'm not trying to be funky
fresh here but I need to understand
because on the one hand you are making
it sound like
it's like oh I'm doing all this work
it's not worth it but then now on this
side you're like oh I only I only do the
management does that make me make sense
I'm just trying to understand yeah yeah
no I yeah for sure
um so I do I'm supposed to eating the
managing but because she's had so many
surgeries and health issues I had to go
in on my time at your time working like
12 hours a day catching up on all the
appointments that we can't just cancel
is she is she paid salary and not not by
dog or Not by total profit
she makes commission so she's not if
she's not cutting and she's not working
then she's not making any money when
she's out on her surgeries right
so so you're having to come in and do it
so it's not the money you don't need the
money per se you just don't have the
time so why can't you hire another
contractor and that way you can keep
earning off the business but you don't
have to pick up her Slack
and then that 47k would just be split
between two people
and then you're still making your 12K
which hey you're making money whatever
if on your own words it doesn't take a
whole lot of work it's just you managing
from your house and then you've got
another contractor that picks up the
slack when old girl can't do it then now
you're now you're going and now you've
just got another business here that like
you said you don't make a ton off of but
you're running it and at any point if
you wanted to expand it and take a
bigger portion of it you could unless
you're just like hey I hate dogs I don't
want to do this anymore I'm out you know
especially not it
um I guess I feel like if I were to hire
another contractor I would be uh
babysitting more
um I trust a swimmer and I I feel I can
leave her when okay is up and running
and I trust her with the money and I
trust her with the dogs and everything
and I feel like it would be more work
for me
it for sure would be but you'd make more
money it sounds like you are you do not
want to be in the business of leadership
yeah because leadership's hard and it's
investing and it's exhausting
um yes and no I mean I do have she's got
the other business though that's what
I'm saying this is um this is where it's
painting me I
here's where as a person who has owned a
similar type business
I guess I had thought about still
helping her
um buy her Contracting Neo if she needs
another surgery
you've got to make a choice
I mean managing it right Abigail here's
what it sounds like you want it sounds
like you want to make more money
you want to go back to doing less work
you want to not deal with management
issues but you do want to be a manager
and you want to hold her accountable but
you don't want to like hurt her feelings
because she's been with you for a long
time and you don't want to add anybody
new because you trust the old person but
the old person doesn't work anymore you
got you got to just make some hard calls
look you're going to be uncomfortable
one way or another so just choose your
discomfort and move forward choose your
discomfort and move forward let me say
this you have someone you trust now and
it took time to build that trust you can
find someone else that you trust you can
add more people and build trust and and
you know learn their integrity over time
that's that's how it works but when it
comes to the sale of this thing I would
Net Present Value it out if this is me
I'm just making up numbers you're it's
so small that you're gonna two or three
years and that's what I would sell it
for that's just me I mean she's got the
assets that she can sell off and her
list of clients yeah yeah multiply that
by I don't know three to five three to
four is usually how it works all right
make your choice Abigail this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
y'all there's a lot you can't control
when it comes to health care but there
is something you should check out that
can help Christian Healthcare Ministries
chm is not Insurance it is
budget-friendly biblically based Health
cost sharing that means a community of
members helping share the burden of each
other's health care costs they help
people just like you in all 50 states so
see if chm could be right for your
family learn more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
foreign
you are listening to the Ramsay show and
in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions on the
debt free stage we got Clint and Lori
from Cleveland Ohio what's going on
[Applause]
is so good wait you guys energy is out
of control
excited I I know I just know that you
guys paid off a monster of debt
what is it 150 3053 months
[Applause]
wow 153
000 and wow what do you do for a living
I'm a civil engineer and I'm a social
worker okay I love it outstanding so you
guys are gonna have to break this down
like tell us a story tell us how all
this tell us how it went down well we we
had credit cards we had
um student loans car loans You Name It
We had it normal yeah yeah so um that at
the end of the year I always kind of
take a time to do like a little
self-evaluation
um going into a new year and that year I
just felt like God was saying to me
you've got to get this right with your
money and
um then I checked out our church webpage
and there was a financial peace class
starting two days later and I'm like
we're going Clinton cancel your plans
for Wednesday night we're gonna be there
so
um we went and uh it was Clint's second
time taking the class my first time what
was it like having a
touchy-feely social worker tell the
engineer we're going to a class about
money oh he's used to it oh yeah yeah if
if she tells me I go you know
engineer I love it that's the last class
of engineering College they're like hey
by the way just say yes yes
just shoot me straight what was your
first impression were you like yes or
were you like like were you skeptical
did it take you a minute to get on board
tell me about that so right when we
started we wanted to give up right away
and Lori will kind of tell you why
um
I I work for the government so we were
on furlough in 2019. okay
um she can kind of tell the rest yeah so
I think we kind of knew a little bit
about what the program was we Clint had
gone through it by himself when we were
engaged and then
um we yeah so we started the class maybe
like two weeks later our hot water
heater went out and then two weeks after
that he went on furlough and we were
like oh my gosh we wanted to quit so bad
and I felt like just getting through
that hurdle and those two hurdles alone
was enough to kind of just like Propel
us through so it was like okay okay it's
gonna be okay we took an 1100 hit like
right off the bat and then we were like
oh my gosh can we do this every part of
us wanted to go and just be like this
doesn't work we're quitting we're giving
up wow and we didn't we kept going well
it probably also made you see like how
precarious your situation can be right
like all it takes is a water heater
going out or being furloughed for you
know just the dominoes to fall all over
the place yeah people think they get a
job in the government it's going to be
stable and slow Forever Until It's just
one Tuesday afternoon it's just not
anymore right yeah yes so 153 000 over
the course of 53k what was this year
what was your income during that time uh
it was 120 to 150 wow
and what was the what accounts for that
increase
um does pay raises over the years areas
over there yeah yeah really very cool
okay so so
what did you do when you got furloughed
because the the psychological data tells
me that when you lose your job when you
get sent home your body responds as
though you've just lost a loved one it's
damaging to the psyche it's damaging
especially for a breadwinner it's a lot
of Shame involved to sit down and tell
your wife hey I don't have a paycheck
anymore like that whole thing is scary
you go home what do you do next
so I went to work
I've been working part-time and I work
at a hospital and I was like I will take
any shift you can give me yes I went to
a bigger Hospital like you know north of
where we live I usually work South where
really I'm like whatever whatever you
have I'll take your weekends I'll take
your holidays I'll take whatever you can
give me and
um so we I mean I was just grinding it
out I cranked it up to full time and we
tried to buried well my brother
yes so what did you do though
um so we
um
[Applause]
so we we had a snowstorm like right when
it happened like 15 inches of snow we
ran out of diapers he was 19 months old
and we just I'm like okay Now's the Time
Now's the Time we're like there's 42 a
month we can save it you can stay here
and potty train okay
you're the only guy in the government
who was on all fours every night just
begging God please let me go back to
work please oh my it's incredible
waiting for it to open back up that is
so I mean most of the time when we talk
to people we're like What was the
hardest part and they're like oh the
budget and you're like
[Laughter]
go to work she was happy to go to work
so okay so you're for furloughed we've
taken extra shifts we're potty training
the kids I want like what were some of
the crazy things that you guys did
because everybody's got that crazy story
of like oh no we only ate Chef Boyardee
you know seven nights a week what was
the thing that you did that was like if
you told your friends hey we're doing
this one thing to pay off debt that they
would think you're crazy
well for me I let her create the budget
she's a free spirit
um she might get on the same page until
until she um and and so when she started
creating the budget we were finally on
the same page although it drove me nuts
because her handwriting was all over the
place she just had scratches oh yeah it
was it was awful wow so you're doing
this Budget on a legal pad like on a
piece of paper not a spaces I love paper
I do not like spreadsheets oh my gosh we
had to hook you guys up with some every
dollar before you get off of here and
get you guys into into the 2000s right
but let me let me ask you this in all
seriousness
um that Journey 55 months that's a long
time that's a long time and there are
nights when you're look over and he is
asleep or she's asleep and you can't you
can't sleep and you're staring at the
ceiling and you're done with the whole
thing you're done with your little boys
not being able to go do stuff you're
done with not being able to see your
kids because you're working 50 shifts a
week you're done with the government job
but you know anywhere else to go you're
done with all of it how do you if
someone is sitting right where you were
and they're three three weeks in or
they're three months in and the whole
thing falls apart
what do you tell them how'd you keep
going
I think the the boys were really our why
I mean
um what I guess the other piece that
wasn't covered in in why the journey
took so long was that um throughout the
course of this we found out that our
youngest child has a extremely rare
genetic disorder and so we cash flowed
tons and tons and tons of medical
appointments hospitals stay a bunch of
GI procedures and therapy I mean we paid
so thousands of Medical on top and we
were able to cash flow that and I think
part of it was like we want to get to
that point where we have the peace like
when we you know like Dr John deloney
says all the time like where we can
sleep at night and know that that we're
gonna be okay and that they're gonna be
okay and if he needs more things down
the road that we can continue to do that
we can continue to cash flow it and and
also just have that peace of mind
mentally as well that's incredible
incredible man there's always more to
the story John they're always there
always is but I I just
can't help but wonder if that whisper in
the night
you're gonna have to get your money
right yeah was hey you're about to head
through a a dark tunnel for a while it's
gonna be tough well I'm so proud of you
guys so so proud of you guys you guys
are rock stars and of course we've got
that living give box for you you can
gift it to somebody else it includes a
Total Money Makeover baby steps
Millionaires and of course a year if you
count them down
bring up the kids let's get a three two
one go quick go quick we're up against
the clock yeah yeah three two two one
we're done
I love it I love it I love it that's
what I'm talking about Clinton Lori
Payne off 153k in 53 months making 120
to 150k that's how you do it guys we're
proud of you this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
what's up guys you're listening to the
Ramsay show I'm Jade warshaw your host
joined by Dr John deloney to my right I
like to call you JD money I'll take it I
like it I'll take it guys if you're
wondering whether to buy or sell a home
this year here's what you need to know
about the housing market there's still
more demand for homes than there are
homes to buy so home prices probably
won't plummet but ongoing interest rate
hikes are making mortgages unaffordable
for some buyers let's be honest about
that so home prices aren't expected to
spike either so what does this all mean
for you that is the question it means if
you're buying a home you may still face
some competition in big price tags and
if you want to sell your home chances
are you can still make a nice profit but
you may have to be patient for the right
offer to come imagine that of course all
that depends on where you are where you
are because every Market is there
different okay that's why you need to
work with an experienced real estate
agent when you're ready to start the
home buying or selling process you want
someone who's done this hundreds of
times before and knows how to negotiate
a strong deal based on a current market
you can find agents like that who are
Ramsay trusted through our endorsed
local providers program they are top
performing agents around the country who
we trust are going to serve you well to
get to to get connected today go to
ramseysolutions.com agent that's
ramseysolutions.com agent and y'all know
I'm always going to tell you I'm gonna
shoot you straight I have used Ramsay uh
endorsed local providers for Real Estate
John when we moved here I'm a shout her
out Mandy Lynn feste she came through in
the clutch man Amanda Lewis was was mine
yes she was awesome she worked with me
for nine months at one point she sat me
down and said you are being unrealistic
okay and she let me have it in the right
way and man we landed on a dream place
so it's been awesome yeah man they shoot
you straight they do not lie I remember
I kind of Wonder I need fried to ask her
I feel like maybe we might have been
tough clients I might I think her my
Amanda's exact quote to me was you're a
very tough client so we're sorry we're
we are high maintenance people over here
a little bit of drama Maybe maybe
William's a little better than us
William in Minneapolis what's going on
in your world
all right guys it's a pleasure to see
the both of you I'm very new to Ramsey
Solutions so uh bear with me
not Cult Don't say this is for sure Colt
William welcome
you guys are great well I will I'll be
coming into
um a pretty sizable inheritance that
will be uh in the form of cash and land
uh but my question really has to do with
the land side of this um the land is
worse in the neighborhood of you know
three million dollars so it's a pretty
sizable amount of land that my family
has you know amassed and passed down
since my you know my family immigrated
here uh so the the generation before my
parents made it very clear to them that
their wish was that the land was not
meant to be sold okay and my parents my
parents honored that and um and added on
to that Land by you know buying up the
acreage next door to it and so on it
kept building out so that honored that
wish and they didn't sell it but they
did not place that expectation on me
um I have moved away and simply don't
want to manage the land even though
there are ways I could generate income
from the acreage you know like logging
or renting out the fields to cover uh
the taxes but I just don't necessarily
want to do that and so essentially do I
have a moral obligation to keep this
land
oh Jay do you mind if I jump in on this
uh go for it John so as somebody who is
scratching and clawing with almost every
spare penny
to purchase land that's going to be
generational land for my family this
one's hard
um
anytime you've got a moral question that
is tough for you to answer
I always want to look at the people you
are not talking to and so have you sat
down with your parents and said hey
what's the expectation with this
property
so when when we did have these
conversations essentially what my father
was big on is
it's going to be your decision but this
is how our family and generations that
have come before us have felt about it
it's the balls in your court then my dad
was pretty clear he's not going to put
that kind of pressure on me but um uh
that he was very clear on how the
previous generations have felt about
this about this land how how has the
land generated income previously
um honestly uh it hasn't uh there's been
uh a couple times where we've logged it
um and then we've rented out a couple
Fields I mean because it's a thousand
plus acres but a really a lot of it is
just for uh recreational use right
four-wheeling hunting but I I don't do
any of that and
um uh so so really it was just it was
meant for enjoyment um really for the
family how is it appreciated over the
last 25 30 years
um
I'm not sure uh because like I said I
mean it's been in our it's been in our
family for well over a hundred years
um and but I'm not sure exactly how it's
appreciated but um I know my my parents
have again some pretty good deals on the
neighboring pieces of land
um because they're so familiar with our
family let me let me back out and ask a
different question do you need this
money
and here's what I'm asking
what if you were given three million
dollars in a
401 portfolio
couldn't touch it until you were 55 or
65 whatever it is
that'd be a pretty incredible gift that
hopefully would appreciate it that what
the average has been over the last 100
years which is about 10 to 12 percent
I can't imagine having this much land
sitting on this for the next 30 years or
however old you are
would it not would you not sell a 100
year old family Legacy and turn around
and dump this money into a a retirement
account
that may or may not perform as well as
this is this property see what I'm
saying
I mean I I do and I mean to your first
question do we need the money I mean my
wife and I were young were 25 and we
don't need the money in the sense of um
we're we're out of debt um and we
unknowingly have been following your
guys's principles but uh we were out of
debt we have our 401ks maxed out we have
about 75 000 in our 401K
um
uh not yet we're we have about 228
thousand dollars left but we'll have
that paid off by the end of next year
let me ask you let me ask you something
let me let me go back to land real quick
how much is it going to cost you out of
your pocket to maintain this land
whether it's keeping it up or taxes
whatever
yeah with uh with taxes and everything
it'll be
um in the neighborhood of 30 to 40 000.
a year
what a year yeah yeah but you can put
some cows on it and that goes away I
mean you there's so many things you can
do with it here yeah yeah a lot of it's
like from property so that's what
I feel like I when you call in you know
all we can tell you is kind of what we
would do you know at the end of the day
you're going to go home and do it what
you think is best and you've kind of
framed it to where you framed it up to
where you understand the weight of this
but there's also kind of you're out
there your dad gave you an out but
obviously that initial cause that's
what's tripping you up and it
I I want to encourage you to take your
time on this I want to encourage you how
long have you had this inheritance
we haven't it's not in our name yet
we're still kind of going through okay
yes I've been known for years even yes
but now it's happening and that's
different from something being
hypothetical is different from when it
actually happens and so I want you this
is weighty to me this doesn't feel like
you're just gonna up and decide I want
you to take time with this because
you're 25 and let me just tell you some
of the decisions I made at 25 if I could
go back and do it I would
um take your time to answer your
question like on I don't think it's a
moral issue in terms of a sin issue or
something like that
I'll tell you we have a disposable world
and we are all about the tragedy of
selling 100 year old property for three
million dollars so y'all could buy a
nice big 9 000 square foot house makes
me just sick to my stomach so to answer
your question all the way through
man I don't know that it's a moral issue
or not an evil person it's not it's not
you couldn't pry this land out of my
hands is what I would say yeah I don't
think it's moral but I do think it's
questioning some things yeah he's got a
lot of things to think about all right I
love the Ramsay show slow play it man
hey it's Dr John deloney if you love the
show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your life and
your money I'm your host Jade warshaw
joins to my right by Dr John deloney
give us a call the number is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
hey I just realized something John
we're not we're no longer building
actual amazing relationships we were
just depends on who's reading it we're
doing all those things you've got calls
about money mental health marriage your
work whatever you got going on we got
you I like that I like this hanging out
to have a conversation about your life
and money that's great it works perfect
all right Sarah your first step to have
a conversation about your life and your
money what's going on in Orlando Florida
Sarah
Hi how are you guys doing good how are
you
I'm good so I am a college student I am
halfway through school and my journey to
get a bachelor's degree and I have a
paid for camper that I am bringing down
from Illinois to live in I am moving out
of a very horrible renters situation
okay and my question is whether or not
to buy a property and put like what I
would pay for rent into a piece of
landlord like doesn't it's undeveloped
and live on the camper in the camper on
that land or to continue renting a like
a camping spot at a campground
let's see let's work through this here
let's find out man I mean I'm I'm biased
towards a certain thought but I don't
want to go there yet until I unpackage
on right so let's go through it do you
have any money that's the first question
like are you in debt
let's let's walk it through all my all
my school is paid for by a full ride
scholarship sweet
um yes so I have no worries about
college all books all College tuition
everything is paid for in that situation
basically I only campers paid for
yeah so campers toilet paper I have no
debt no I don't even own a credit card I
love it like I I I'm a I'm a Dave Ramsey
Baby I was serious I'm Dave Ramsey
hold on you can't be all the way to Dave
Ramsey baby because he has a thing in
his soul about living in campers yes he
does oh okay so I drop like a rock when
you said you had a horrible living
experience was it in the camper
no no no it was in a renter's situation
so currently my
um renting situation kind of
um
the fact of the matter is I don't have a
kitchen and I barely have a bathroom in
my renting situation okay and as soon as
this lease ends you're out of there bye
Felicia okay but have you have you
just because you had one bad renting
situation doesn't mean the other one
another one is going equally bad right
um because you've basically chosen
murder and murder as your other two
options I'm gonna get a camper and move
to Raw land in the woods or I'm gonna
move into like a campground and cross my
fingers when did you get the camper
about six months ago so you've had it
I've lived I've lived in a camper before
I've lived in two other camping type
situations and personally I love it like
I was a handy person I work on my own
car I'm like my dad's a mechanic
um my adopted dad was an electrician so
I'm very handy I've learned a lot of
things about how to be self-sufficient
what's the price difference like what
are we looking at verse you versus you
living getting you know renting a plot
of land for the camper versus you doing
a traditional like renting situation in
an area you can afford what are we
looking at
price wise so the camber would be 800 a
month all utilities included Wi-Fi
through our water everything okay well
we already know the average apartment
price that is not a dump like what I'm
moving out of here is thirteen hundred
dollars yeah okay and
how much money do you have saved
about 20 000 and if I were to buy land
it'd be 12 months from now and I'm
hoping to have like a down payment date
of like 30 000. I would not buy land and
here's why yeah we're talking about
renting land no no she wants to buy land
or go to a campground I would not buy
land because you don't know how long
you're going to be in this area and you
think you know like no no when I get out
of college I'm gonna I would not put
down Roots like that I would recommend
any if you even if you said hey I'm a
first year college grad I would tell you
to rent because the you don't want to be
tied down to something I would much hey
man 800 bucks for all the utilities
that's not a bad that ain't bad and
especially if you love that lifestyle
but hear us when we say please don't buy
it just yeah don't buy land what are you
thinking about buying just just because
I gotta know because you sound
incredible
in my thought like I've done all the
numbers I um I'm a numbers person my
degree will be in business
so I wanted to buy an acre put a um
electric and water on the property for a
camper and then possibly build like two
or three other spots to rent to people
in the area because camping is huge in
Florida like that's like the retiree
lifestyle I think that's Mark is very
big for it here and then you're amazing
you've got to help pay for them like I'd
want to pay the mortgage off in like
less than two years how much does it
cost to put a well on property
about twenty thousand dollars are you
confident in that because my neighbor
just put one in for forty five thousand
and they missed and they do it again
well the water table here is really high
like the the
that is well here would only be like 10
or 15 feet how much does it cost to run
power to put a pole in and run power
well I'd have my dad help me so like I
know but someone's got to come in from
the city and run a
yeah I just love the fact that you're
you're a gangster dude you're so awesome
the way that you're thinking is is
wonderful I think that again for now
renting is the way because you're still
halfway through school you've got a lot
on your plate so let's not let's just do
one thing at a time and I love that
you're paying for school I love that
you're in such a cash positive position
with your money no debt you've got the
savings you know look for a great place
to rent and I know that you could even
look for folks like private land and
contact those folks and see if you can
you know rent their land for a while the
renting situation is a private like
um that's all I've looked into that yeah
okay great and then I like I feel like
you're already a student of this but
keep being a student of how this works
and that way when you're ready if you
decide in two years or whatever that you
still want to move forward with this
purchase of land and you know create all
this stuff then you're even more
confident in in that endeavor so here's
here's kind of the principles or the
values in order get out of school
without owing anybody anything and don't
take the risk proposition right now
versus the reward the risk that you get
in there and you get a mess you get
somebody that you rented out of property
and they burn the place down or they end
up being a lunatic or whatever that risk
is not worth you getting out of college
you have a Willy Wonka ticket you've got
everything paid for get out of college
with 25 or 30 or 40 Grand in the bank
with no debt in game like you're already
launched out of the system and like Jade
said keep doing your research on this
because I think this is in your future
I'm confident the reason I'm being super
nice to use I'm fairly certain I'm going
to work for you someday like you were so
far ahead of where I could ever be when
it comes to entrepreneurial spirit and
already figuring stuff out that's
amazing your parents did a great job
um but yeah get principle number one get
out of this thing debt free just get out
of school no risk don't don't don't go
bananas and then principle two is start
investing in your future when you walk
across that stage
man and she knows the lingo she was
talking the talk walking the walk proud
of you Sarah I can't wait to see man
you're gonna like really be an
influential business person land owner
one day I love it she's a boss this is
the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
hey what's going on guys this is Jade
you're listening to the Ramsey Show I'm
joined by my host co-host Dr John
deloney mental health extraordinaire
probably a bit of a stretch
no you know what you're talking about
and so that's why if you're listening
and you have a problem it could be money
related it could be relationship related
it could be a little bit of both be sure
to give us a call the number is AAA
825-5225 we want to listen and we want
to help you sort it through whatever it
may be
um and speaking of sorting through
problems John this right here you guys
you know we always get articles that
come through our email or you know
sometimes the show producers are like
guys you gotta look at this
this article right here is something
definitely worth talking about just the
title alone like made my ears perk up it
says five signs that you will never
become rich one day it ain't happening
basically if you fall into some of the
categories that are listed here and it
sounds funny to say but it's actually
pretty serious so let's let's just kind
of work through these five John because
I feel like this is I mean it's it's
accurate
um how do you know that you will never
be rich
number one you have a victim let's go
through it first you have a victim
mentality two saying money is not
important to me three you love to spend
more money than you make four you have a
scarcity mindset and five you're
obsessed with being the best in your
business you're not obsessed with being
the best in your business so let's let's
break it on down here because I I know
the two that stood out to me that I've
struggled with what's that the struggle
is you have a victim mentality okay I
hate to say a lot of these um you just
say that money is not important to me
because I grew up with that like oh oh I
don't want to be a millionaire you know
if you have a million dollars I mean
that's just gonna change who you are and
we don't need that and rich people are
like this and rich people are like that
and it's kind of like you negative your
way out of
you you make something that's great
sounds so terrible who would ever want
that there's a uh an old Methodist
minister in Texas that says the most
offensive word of the English language
is they and when you grow up with those
people with that kind of money are them
yeah it creates this little false cocoon
around we don't like that yeah right
yeah and that's a great recipe for
sitting right where you are forever well
and it goes both ways because you can
paint those people to be like these
horrible people like
you know just mean rich people or
they're evil yeah
greedy old rich people or which I also
saw this growing up is they're just
the people on the hill like they're
they're sparkly and they're shiny
imperfect and they had all this
opportunity and there there must be like
this special gleam about them and that's
how they got it and we're not those
people you know we're not the people who
invest we didn't get lucky yeah we don't
we don't wear a suit and title work we
don't carry a briefcase and so we don't
invest and we don't build wealth and if
we do we don't talk about it because I
never heard about it so that for sure
and then the victim mentality of it it
goes hand in hand because it's like if
only they would have done that then I
could have had this
or if only they hadn't have done that I
could have had this and at some point
you just gotta leave that by the wayside
and go hey that just was what it was and
now
it's not about what happened it's about
what happens next and I get to decide
what happens next well and I remember
looking at I mean you had more I
remember looking at six figures of
student loan debt and my first thought
was that what they did heck yeah I
signed my name to that paper did I fully
know what I was getting into no but I
signed it man and I can sit there and
stare at it and yell and scream yeah at
what they did or I can get about solving
the problem absolutely get myself in the
problem and that's the hard part right
because the fact is we do know that
student loans and all that kind of stuff
we do know that situations can be
predatory we do know that you can be
done wrong right and it's not negating
the fact that something happened
was or was not wrong right absolutely
but it's just it takes some fortitude
man to come in and be like despite that
I may have played a role in this
especially when it comes to debt and
I've just developed this thought in my
mind now where it's like whatever it is
that I'm complaining about yapping about
whining about there's probably something
Jade that you can do to make it better
instead of claiming it's all them or all
that or you know I'm married so you know
I can always be like it's Sam warshaw no
Jade you look at you too and everybody's
participating yes yeah can't be the
victim mentality but changing that is so
so hard it's so so hard
um you love to spend more money than you
make we wouldn't have a show if it
wasn't for that we all struggle with
that oh man
um yeah that one kind of stands on
itself the one that stuck out to me was
you have a scarcity mindset and that's
one of those like instagrammy buzzword
things that I kind of roll my eyes at
yeah until
I met Dave quite honestly behind closed
doors
and I've heard how people first hand
talk about who are buddies with Joe
Rogan
that he's so insanely generous behind
closed doors that the whole the whole
pitch is there's so much more than
enough for all of us yeah and that's a
true way that dude lives his life
with Dave there's always so much more
that opportunity than there is ever
going to be people to do the work of
course it's a spirit with which they
live and so if it's like oh we'll just
take that like man that's expensive I he
he was buying something and I uh and the
guy came in here and I said hey put one
on for me because I want to buy one of
those
well he just put on Dave's Tab and so I
put some money by Dave saying for it and
I had that money on my desk that same
money I put he he put it on my desk and
he's like he's like dude there's more
than enough there's more than enough but
it's how you tip it's how you live and
so this scarcity mindset if I don't get
mine then someone's gonna get mine yeah
that is a way to
live a tiny shriveled up life but it's a
miserable way of existing I've always
heard the phrase I heard this phrase
when I was in college and I say it to
this day as a reminder
what God has for you is for you
and it kind of whenever I feel that
feeling of if I don't get to this in
time it's gone or if I don't do this
there's only a little bit left I love
the way this says that it says believing
that success is a pie with limited
slices and I always have to remind
myself no Jade and for anybody listening
God has a special plan for you it's not
contingent upon whether other people do
what they were supposed to do or if
other people are successful or not it's
just you and your plan and you competing
with yourself and you getting better
than your former self it's not every you
know what I mean like don't get me wrong
we're all connected but this idea that
somebody can take something from me
That was supposed to be mine
I don't believe that I think that the
only person that can hinder you is you
and no one's gonna steal well my
business would have grown if it wasn't
for that guy over there no you there was
probably something you were supposed to
do well if it wasn't for you know
student loans I could have been Rich by
now no it's probably like I don't
believe that somebody can steal like
your purpose and your what's meant for
you from you I don't know is that
controversial no no I I I I just love
the idea that
there's enough there's enough there's
enough there's enough what's for you is
for you but you got to be the one to go
out and get it the last one is
um I struggle with this one
because I see the other side I see the
the mental health issue side of this
thing I'm gonna be speaking at entree
Summit it would be twenty five hundred
three thousand Business Leaders I see
them struggle with this but at the same
time
it's the truth I don't know a way around
it you're not obsessed with being the
best in your business
like and I think the best in your
business we have transposed to winning
like I have to win and if your obsession
was is with winning at all cost you're
going to find yourself banging on trash
cans to cheap pitches right like my
beloved Astros did they stopped trying
to be excellent at everything and they
start trying to win everything and you
cut corners but if you get obsessed with
Excellence yeah and honoring the person
who put gave you their money or their
time and ask you to help solve a problem
in their business and you become
obsessed with Excellence dude and if
you're not obsessed with it you still do
business don't do business absolutely
absolutely no I mean I gotta say I agree
with this list looking at it I've been
all of the people on here at least once
if not many many times in my life and
yeah me too if you can't get a hold of
just a couple of these you're on your
way you are well on your way
um I mean that's my story I'm sticking
to it
what you think John don't be a victim
make your money if your money's not
important to you it's gonna be important
to somebody else don't spend more than
you make there's always more than enough
and be obsessive about Excellence I love
that this is the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
hey what's going on guys you're
listening to the Ramsay show I'm Jade
warshaw your host joined by Dr John
deloney mental health expert and just
overall good dude let's go with that
I'll take that that's the nicest thing
someone said about me today I will say
yes John deloney an upstanding human
being ladies and gentlemen well you know
what else is Eddie Colin out there in
the in the lobby one of the nicest guys
you'll ever meet that is a fact Eddie
Cullen is one of the nicest guys you'll
ever meet and let me just throw this out
here he's hosting a Financial Peace
University class and if you haven't
joined a class you should go ahead and
join his class uh all the personalities
are hosting classes I am at smack dab
knee deep in the middle of one John
deloney YouTube yes killing the game
when I tell you guys people are changing
their lives I mean that so if you
haven't signed up already and you're
interested in just doing things a little
bit differently with your finances and
making some traction sign up for a
Financial Peace University class or if
you just need a little bit of advice
with your life and your money you can
give us a call here the number is Triple
Eight
825-5225 and with that we're going to
talk to Jesse in Nashville Tennessee
what's going on Jesse how's it going
everybody doing good how are you I'm
doing well um my question is I'm 24
years old my wife and I are officially
in baby step number four um
and I'm curious if we should start the
next baby step or keep investing in my
business to grow it
well if you're in baby step four
you need to do baby step four which is
putting 15 of your income aside for
retirement right so we do need to do
that and then technically you're doing
four five six simultaneously so do you
have kids college to think about
um not yet so we're we're almost a year
married so we're not even okay so we can
kind of cross that out for now here's my
scary question for you
my scary question is are you running
this business out of your personal
family Finance accounts
because Investing For into your business
should be business money that you have
made that you're choosing to reinvest
into your business sure correct yeah
yeah so there's there's about 200k in a
business account and then there's a
fully funded emergency fund about of
about twenty thousand for your first
business or for personal for personal
okay that doesn't bro town in Motown you
got to separate these things apart okay
okay it's gonna get messy messy real
quick so you would have a set of
reserves in your business retained
earnings that you can keep kind of as
savings for what you might need in your
business now I will say if you're just
getting a business off the ground
sometimes you might Infuse your business
with some personal cash of course but in
this case I mean you said you've got
200k I feel like there's John what John
is saying is right
your personal investing has nothing to
do with your business investing unless
I want to learn more about that are you
taking a draw are you paying yourself a
salary no I'm not paying a salary so
um I it's kind of just like a owner's
personal paying expense so I kind of oh
bro so you're just basically running a
business and you're using the business
accounts to like run your life basically
no we don't want to do that dude you got
to separate that instantly are about to
yeah you just it it's easy like simple
it you can start today like you just
need to like head down to the bank set
up a business account doing business as
whatever and well sorry it's for context
sake no no I have an LLC set up like
this whole business like legally
structured it's just I know but you're
living out of that structure and when it
comes to tax you're going to find
yourself in a mega mess
okay yeah we're we're setting aside a a
decent amount every month into taxes
okay that's good you just basically what
you want to make sure and you probably
need to work with a bookkeeper or you
know CPA somebody to help you out so
that you understand what's technically a
business expense what's not because you
don't want to use your business account
to buy your son a new pair of shoes
right because that's not really a
business expense however if you went to
dinner and you were talking business
with somebody that you're you know
Consulting with that could be a business
expense and so you just want to make
sure you understand that and basically
just understand personal savings it's
personal savings and business savings is
business savings and as much it sounds
like you have built the business enough
to where you're taking profit from the
business and reinvesting it into the
business as opposed to having to give
yourself like personal cash infusions
right exactly yeah okay but you also
have a single credit card or a single
debit card and you are paying for
groceries with that paying for your car
with that right yeah so I'm moving money
out of the business account into a like
a Opera like a personal expense again
yeah dude it's so much cleaner if you
just pay yourself a thousand bucks a
month or whatever your whatever you need
pay yourself a salary you can it helps
but that helps with taxes too but it
keeps everything so so clean and
whatever you decide to pay yourself
you're gonna take 15 of that and invest
it because you're in baby step four if
it's if it's 2 000 bucks a month and
it's 25 24 Grand a year that's you
choose to pay yourself
that's how you're gonna buy groceries
and that's how you're gonna buy a car
that's how you're gonna buy stuff then
you're gonna take 15 of that then the
rest of the money that's in your
business you can reinvest that in your
business that's you're responsible for
growing your business however you you
think it's going to work
um Jesse how are you investing right now
because are are you doing like a
individual 401K do you have a sep or are
you investing through your wife's job
how are you doing it honestly I have you
know put all of my effort and energy
towards the business and so I haven't
really done any I mean there's probably
a thousand dollars in a Schwab account
right now that you know Roth IRA or
something yeah otherwise I've just put
all my energy in the last year into
getting into getting to this point where
I could you know have this kind of
conversations so cool good work man is
it is is there other work going on like
does your wife have
yeah my wife's a ICU nurse so okay so
she's got retirement funds set up yes
okay sweet so the 15 is going there
first
well can you just live off her salary
right now while you're building this
business
that is a good possibility I don't think
that's out of scope so you may want to
sit down and look at that because it
might be that you're a you're able to
live off your wife's salary which is
going to be excellent because she's
doing great hard work and you're able to
invest in this business
sounds like things just are a little bit
messy is the business kind of taken off
on you it has over the last like four
months congratulations what's the
business
uh we provide digital marketing and
software for a variety of different
businesses outstanding well done man
well done thank you
I would sit down with it like you're at
a place now we got a couple hundred
thousand dollars in the bank a year to
place now you need to sit down with an
accountant if you haven't already and
beginning we have an accountant right
now yeah you all need to sit down and
map it out to make sure everything is
super clean
um and then you and your wife sit down
with the budget man yeah that's good
cool yeah if you get to the point you
know I would definitely start with Roth
IRAs and match Max those out when you're
doing your baby step four and then
whatever 401K you know your wife has
through her job and then if you get to
the point where we're maxing out all
that as well then you know look to your
business and see what's what's possible
there with your an accountant
did we answer your question
I think there's like another question I
have out of which you guys have uh
helped me with um bring it and I think
it's just really the balance between you
know like I could you know hire some
coaches to help with scaling and getting
more revenue or
like you know putting a down payment on
a house you know it's just what's like
what's the right balance for this stage
you're at which is kind of
you know in a cool place because we just
paid off the last bit of the student
loans so I mean it's just what at what
stage do you say okay I'm gonna take out
you know a down payment down payment for
a home and you know what go towards the
next baby steps what Sam and I did is we
were focused on building our personal
life a little bit more so than we were
building our business so whenever there
was a question of should we focus more
on paying off debt or you know building
the business it was more like no we want
to be able to breathe in life so let's
do let's focus on the debt first and
then when the debt is gone we'll be able
to pay ourselves less and then focus
more into the business and so that's
kind of how we did it
um I like John's idea of paying yourself
a set salary but I do understand that
sometimes when your goals change and you
have the ability to pull more out and
pay yourself more you do and then when
you're like no now I wanna so I do
understand that that can change
um depending on you know the size of
your business and where you're at but
here's what's been valuable for me my
wife and I and our we've been married
with God Almighty almost 21 years is
every time we hit a season like this
like you guys you and your wife have
been running for your lives y'all have
been busting it what you haven't never
done probably is sit down and dream
about what comes next so go out and have
an incredible breakfast in the morning
and the sun shining here in Nashville
and talk about a future together and
that's going to help like what's more
important we need a house right now or
the next five years we're gonna grow
this business you'll work on that Vision
together and some of those answers like
like Jay said her and Sam had worked
that out here's our vision and those
answers kind of work themselves out when
you and your wife are on the same this
is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
hey what's going on guys it's your host
Jade warshaw joined by John deloney this
is the Ramsay show our scripture and
quote of the day the way of a fool is
right in his own eyes but a wise man is
he who listens to counsel Proverbs 12 15
love that one and of course from the man
Prince he says I like constructive
criticism from smart people that's what
I'm saying I'm not taking it from
anything less that's fantastic so yeah
some of y'all I'm talking to somebody
right now some of y'all's criticisms
that I see on the interwebs
I'm not taking it I'm not even listening
to it not smart people it's not from
smart people that's how it goes that is
how it goes all right give us a call the
number is Triple A
825-5225 dawn from Los Angeles
California
what's going on
thank you so much for having me thanks
for calling what can we help you with
so I'm in baby step number one but I
racked up a considerable amount of debt
um throughout the pandemic including the
purchase of a new vehicle and in
listening to you guys I'm wondering if I
should just sell my car and try to buy
another one for cash yeah so tell us a
little bit about this car situation what
are you what's the vehicle would you buy
would you um it's a 2020 Ford Escape
which I use for work every day I'm it's
a great reliable vehicle I'm sure but it
is definitely nicer than what I need and
as I've been just listening to the
Ramsay show and realizing what a
financial impact it's making on my
already existing debt I've just been
wondering if it would be a better idea
to
um to sell it and buy another one cash
yeah so let's break down the numbers
um what'd you spend on it
um it was
about 40. I've been paying I've paid
probably about 10 000 off so far in the
last three years so you owe about 30 30
yeah and uh if you were to sell it today
what's it worth
I don't even know
okay so that's the first thing we want
to look at because if you owe 30 on it
and if you were to sell it you know it's
they'd only give you 20 or something
like that for we need to understand that
so that's the first thing I would look
at now let's take a look at your income
so you spent 40K on a vehicle what's
your take-home pay every month
or your yearly income however you want
three to five thousand a month
okay yeah
a little too much car I would say on
that yeah
um any other debt do you have
got about twenty thousand dollars of
credit card debt and about 30
000 in loans yeah okay yeah we gotta get
out of this car
20 000 a credit card debt 30 000 in
loans explain to me the spread on your
income you said between three to five
thousand dollars that's a big spread
help me understand that
so I'm a massage therapist and I'm in
school right now to become a physical
therapist so I don't work regular hours
I'm not on a regular salary I'm
basically just available for when my
clients need me okay
during the pandemic I wasn't able to
work at all legally so that was a major
impact and part of the reason that I
started taking out loans
okay so you were just taking out loans
and credit cards to just fund your life
and not working
yes okay so do you recognize the
we're never gonna do that again ever
oh yeah ever ever ever ever ever this is
a series of horrible decisions and I'm
so glad that I decided to to try and
reach out to find some sort of a
financial advisor who pointed me to the
Dave Ramsey website awesome
um and I've been learning about how to
manage personal finances Welcome to our
crazy gang man we got you so you're
you're schooling right now is it is it
full-time tell me about your school I
want to get an idea of your time
um what your time looks like I'm in
school full-time I'm working as close to
full-time as I can
um and just basically running into way
too much month at the end of my money
and just you know my credit cards they
are ranging from about 25 to 30 interest
each month
the payments that I'm making are not
even really making a dent I'm just
drowning yeah so the key here the key
here is you got to get your income up
how much school do you have left
how much how much time until school's
done
six years wait you just started
six years I I I've been a small business
owner for 10 years and I just just
jumped back into school uh last semester
to get my
um Bachelor's in kinesiology so that I
can apply to a physical therapy program
yeah excellent all right can you are you
are you casual in this you're taking out
student loans
I've taken out student loans as well
because that's part of the loan yeah we
got it I guess you gotta I hate to tell
you you gotta stop we gotta stop we
gotta stop and back up because
we you started going full steam ahead on
a good intentioned plan but with a yeah
with a bad strategy
does that make sense good intention that
you want to get your income you want to
you know get your education change
careers love that but let's do it the
right way because you are I mean like
you said you're barely making you're
making three thousand bucks a month
barely making payments on this stuff
we've got to find a way that we can go
in an order that makes sense
um right now there is a trade that you
or skill set that you have that you know
how to do and you can make money on it I
I would love to see you get control of
this financial situation and then work
towards a way that you can Finance
school pay for school so that you're not
taking out student loan debt because
right now otherwise you're gonna you're
gonna wake up in six years you're gonna
owe 150 000 in addition to all this
money yeah we're not going forward like
we would not love you if we said this is
a great idea and both Jade and I have
been to a lot of college we both believe
in school and I love school that's right
but you are you are man you are you're
trying to put out a fire with a
blowtorch
feels like like yeah you got to stop the
step one to getting out of debt is stop
getting in more debt yeah that draw a
line in the sand that's no longer never
again yeah
do you see what we're saying we're
coming down on your heart and I I don't
want you to think that we're squashing
your dreams we're just saying in a
minute okay right yeah no I I understand
and that's why I was so I couldn't
believe that he kind of stick my call
because I've been listening to your show
and I just thought man I wish I could
just ask them yeah I wish I could just
ask somebody look Don okay yes so what
we're doing is we're we're gonna cool it
on school for a second so that we can
come up with a plan and tonight I want
you in your journal to go okay here's
what I want to accomplish I want to you
you want to get out of debt we know that
you're wondering about the car so that's
what I want you to write you know just
scribble it out debt okay cars first
think we're gonna think we're gonna get
out of this car we need to find out if
you're writing it down now find out what
the car is worth because we want to make
sure that we can sell it do we need to
get a little loan to cover the
difference and get out of that car and
then get just a little beater car cash
great that eliminates 30k of debt and
you know what I mean by a beater two
thousand three thousand five thousand
dollar car all right yeah the next thing
we're thinking about is income we're not
making enough income and the income we
have is not steady so we need to be
thinking about okay you've got a skill
set let's get some full-time numbers
going because once you get those
full-time numbers going we can start
smashing this debt and we can start
making a plan to save for school and the
faster that we can save for school the
faster you can go to school and in the
meantime I want you to start making a
plan for school and we're just writing
this down what comes first what comes
second what comes third and the school
thing right now John you can tell me if
you think I'm wrong I think right now
school is third
because you have a way that you can earn
money it's something you're good at at
some point you you enjoyed it what
school are you going to
with Los Angeles College okay
um is this for your undergrad degree
yeah I originally got my associates in
Psychology so I'm starting back to get
an associate to transfer in kinesiology
to get the bachelor's to get accepted to
the Physical Therapy Program okay so
here's what I want you to do
um I had both my knees done two summers
ago and my physical therapist was
incredible
that's awesome guess where she went to
school
I have no idea
when you are paying for college
for college with cash you go for the
free option you go for the cheap option
you go for the best option for your for
your buck and so like Jade said I think
she's right I think it's number three
and I think you spend some time shopping
shopping shopping
and find a great education option that's
going to be that's going to fit your
budget Don thank you for the call look
you're on the right track you just need
to pull back a little bit and start
doing it the right way and that's just
thing one thing two thing three in order
of importance making sure that you're
doing this thing without a sense of debt
all right that does it for this hour be
sure to join us next time you can tell
me you won't do it but please don't tell
me you can't this is the Ramsay show
you like what you heard in this episode
and want to know more about getting
started on the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsesolutions.com and click the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]